so because I already have a video on
Jane Foster for as well as Odin son I
thought it might be fun to make a video
on the elusive character known as rune
King Thor and how he ties into the
odinforce and Secret Wars
so as its name suggests the odinforce is
the source of Odin's power and the basis
for his position as a ruler of Asgard
and Thor vol 1 issue number 349 Marvel
tells us that in his youth Odin and his
two brothers had come face-to-face with
Surtur a fire demon who is said to bring
about the end times of Asgard attempting
to subvert suitors power by sealing the
flames of destruction sorter engages in
a battle with the group while Odin's
brothers are killed in the fight their
death creates a merging of their life
forces with Odin himself as a result
Odin is bestowed with the odinforce an
infinite source of energy capable of
manipulating entire universes and
altering realities
now again touching back to my video on
Ragnarok we had talked about how this
event centered on the death of Odin
Loki's war against asgaard and the Exile
of Thor to provide a bit of a refresher
here in for volume 2 issue number 40
Odin had engaged Surtur in a battle on
earth alongside most of the Asgard's as
one of the first stages of Ragnarok
which is the cycle of the death of all
the Asgardians and the revenge will
rebirth the Surtur would amass an army
and invade earth with the intention of
destroying it in order to keep us from
happening and prevent Ragnarok Odin
inserter fought one another and were
believed to have died in the process
while the battle actually ended with the
transitioning of Odin inserter to the
space between dimensions the purpose of
this story was to simply remove Odin
from the landscape of the mainstream
Marvel continuity and so with Odin gone
Loki initiated his plans for the
continuation of Ragnarok by raising his
own army composed of the enemies of the
s guardians and during the initial
battle overpowering and banishing Thor
while Thor was able to rally what was
left of the Asgardians in order to make
preparations for their war against Loki
and to take a scart back Authority be
victorious his skill and strength alone
would not be enough to overcome Loki and
so in an effort to compensate for this
he sought out to follow the same path
Odin had taken in order to gain the
ability to use the odinforce
as well as decipher the runes of Asgard
Venturi to a place called Hill stof
which is referred to as a land where all
things are seen the Thor is actually met
with a physical manifestation of the
odinforce itself with the odinforce
operating as a guide of sorts boar
begins to undertake the journey to
become the rune King which is
accomplished in three stages the first
being sacrifice
the second being knowledge of the past
and the third being knowledge of the
rooms following the path of Odin by
first approaching the well of Mamere
Thor is told by the odinforce that his
first stage of sacrifice can only be
achieved by sacrificing both of his eyes
the reason for this is that while the
well only requires one eye to gain
knowledge of the past
Odin is the only person to have ever
visited the well after sacrificing one
of his eyes
Odin was able to gain knowledge of the
past but because walking the exact same
path as Odin would not give him the
power he seeks Thor comes to the
realization that he has to walk the path
not traveled and so after plucking out
his eyes the water for the whale began
to gush forward and after partaking from
the waters Thor achieves the second
stage of becoming the room King by
learning of the entire history of Asgard
and the nine realms from the time life
first came into existence up until the
current moment now following this Thor
undertakes the final task in order to
gain knowledge of the runes attaching a
chain to its Raziel The Tree of Life
four hangs himself for nine days and
nights during which time he gains the
knowledge necessary to decipher the
runes of Asgard while were not told how
this is possible or how these ruins work
what we are told is that his knowledge
of the past coupled with his deciphering
of the runes allows him to know all
things from the past and the future as
well as control all things in the
present again this is very ambiguous
here because Marvel doesn't really
provide an exact definition of what
these things mean however with his
newfound power combined with the power
of the odinforce Thor is reborn as ruin
King Thor
now while the rest of this event is
covered in my Ragnarok video the
question becomes this how powerful is
rune King Thor blast stated rune King
Thor has the full power of the odinforce
combined with the wisdom of the well of
manure and the knowledge of the Tree of
Life
what this means is that rune King Thor
can warp reality and has knowledge of
all things that will happen all things
that aren't happening and all things
that have happened however because this
version of thor only appears for two
issues his actions are combined Asgard
and Marvel doesn't explicitly tell us
how he compares to other beams we're
going to have to do a bit of twisting
and turning to determine working ranks
in comparison to individuals like the
cosmic entities the first example model
gives us is Odin and Galactus and the
Mighty Thor issue number 5 in 2011 woful
presents us with a scenario where Odin
fights Galactus while Odin is able to
open up the battle by head-butting
Galactus the power required to achieve
such a feat that is to say to injure
Galactus resulted in Odin using the full
power of the odinforce as a result he
fell into the odinsleep
in order to recharge his energies
however almost immediately after this
Galactus gets up and seems almost
completely unaffected by Odin's attack
now taking this example and bringing in
the ones who sit above in shadow who
were abstract beings that fed off the
death of the Asgardians and their
rebirth during the rocky rock event Odin
had previously attempted to kill these
beings but was unable to do so however
during the Ragnarok story rune King Thor
was successfully able to kill them but
died in the process now the death of
rune King Thor was not due to anyone
killing him but was actually due to the
fact that destroying the 1 through said
11 shadow meant ending everything in
Asgard including Thor himself
and so using the transitive property we
can make a legitimate case here that if
Odin was able to injure Galactus but not
able to destroy the ones who sit above
in shadow but ruin King Thor was able to
destroy the ones who sit above in shadow
but it stands to reason that ring King
Thor is probably around the same level
as Galactus in terms of power but again
this is a little bit of a stretch now in
terms of Secret Wars one of the
questions that I've been asked
as whether or not the room King Thor in
this series is the same as the room King
Thor from Ragnarok to be honest here
it's really just a guess but it's
entirely possible because characters
like frog Thor a character named Simon
Walter sinned from the mainstream
continuity exists in the Thor series it
seems that Marvel was simply just
grabbing the most popular versions of
for and throwing them in however this
version of four bears a striking
resemblance to King Thor who arrived
after the Civil War event was over and
had rebuilt Asgard but because Marvel
hasn't offered a definitive explanation
as to which version of four this is at
this point it's really just kind of a
guessing game with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end I hope you guys enjoyed it and
I will catch you guys later peace